ay as usual reminded me what what we
should do today cuz I didn't know if we
are all going to have a chess class or
something else and not just the chest
pass continuing Main in two very correct
ADI so our first position on the board
white is to play and somewhat I'm quite
certain that if this was a normal game
everyone would have Play Bishop take
Rook super
fast or might think about it but we know
that there is little bit more Okay C is
making his way in super speed and we
need to find Checkmate in two moves for
white and remember no three moves no
four moves if if you if you can win a
game by using more moves that's
perfectly okay but when you have a
puzzle that says specifically Checkmate
in two moves anything other than that is
wrong so why to play Checkmate in two
moves how does white play and check
meate in two M and this
well we're going to see two important
Checkmate patterns
here yes
um Bishop
B7 and what are the checkmates after
Bishop
B7 um where where are we threatening the
checkm um the
like uh the queen to which squares we
will speak like CHS right the queen
moves to where you we should be
seven
and and there's another
Checkmate so that is perfect move and
the queen is threatened Checkmate on A7
and A8 right we instead of saying the
queen moves up which is totally correct
I know that your answer was perfect but
we should also speak like chess Queen A7
or queen A8 both of them are checkmates
so if the queen takes the Knight okay
now no no Queen A7 it's not protected
but Queen A8 and if we eliminate the
bishop either with the black's Bishop
or with the
king in either way this is
Checkmate right and it's mainly
because the Rook is preventing the king
to from
escaping okay why to
play
ad do you think you know or you know
that you
know know you think you know okay what
do you
know what why to
play Queen H that's okay start check how
many moves does black have one so super
forcing right not forcing but super
forcing one move and
now very
good no all or or what yes what or C8
really are we certain about Rook
C8 oh no or tiny L certain why why
not hey Will the Knight will the if
after Rook C8 Bishop take his knight7
Checkmate no
exactly like every every extra word that
you say takes of what someone said
before right it should be but very nice
because after the bishop take suddenly
this direction is open for the queen
okay that this this was really really
straightforward okay let's look at the
next ones all righty why to play
Checkmate in two
moves
yesen
on
D and then black is one move right you
move the Rook first to G8 but if you
move the Rook to G8 black and take
it he doesn't Hur I no but but but if
you play this black is just going to
take which Mo which Rook do you want to
move to to here after
it
close
yes Queen takes d8 check King takes d8
Rook f8 checkm right right very good now
first of all if a queen goes to a square
that there is a piece we always have to
say capture because if not there is a
something there so you are replacing it
so Queen captures Rook all right now
here is the big
thing The Rook on G7 is guarding the
seventh rank or second rank so the king
cannot cross
and this is basically Checkmate
on Checkmate on the back rank right it
doesn't matter if there were two pawns
here and the King could not
Escape
or a knight and a rook the king could
also not Escape or even if this bishop
would not be here if the bishop is not
here actually then black can block right
that's why they put the bishop here this
is Checkmate on the back Rank and very
important there was no way for black to
avoid it for example
example would this be Checkmate in two
moves not at all the by the way here is
a great example would this be Checkmate
in two moves not at all would this be a
good move no excellent because the king
cannot take it Checkmate and after this
what would be a good move to continue
just so we see
yesen Tak
Che I forgot about don't forget about
those Bishops in the game I think for
example check and going to win the game
two move check two move Checkmate but
the question if it is if it's black to
play What Would black play here if it's
black to play What Would black play
here take the queen you know take the
queen e the good move and winning the
game but almost always people young kids
cannot is this taking the queen cannot
but is Knight H3 Checkmate better than
taking the queen in both situations you
would win the game but it's really
important to take a deep breath whenever
we can take the queen sometimes it will
cost you a game for quite for certain
you will take a queen and get checkmated
probably more than one time but then you
will study but it's good take the queen
is a winning but black has Checkmate in
one so we know that our job with is to
checkm in two
moves so white has to checkm in two
moves
here
I yes
it D Queen to where d8 but but how come
Queen d8 is going to to be a
Checkmate well why would Queen d8 lead
to a checkmate at
all the will take it right because if he
takes the night does he have to take no
so why would it be Checkmate I know that
how many many many I could say many for
until we finish the lecture and then a
bit more kids like to think that way I
will play a move and my opponent will
take the Knight so if that is the
situation I could go here he would take
Checkmate I would go anywhere that's
protecting the Knight but why would the
opponent take it's such important
concept to understand the opponent he
not there to help you right he will play
any other move other than take he can
Checkmate you in one move he can just do
any other thing you need to find
Checkmate in two
moves Queen takes A7 check KN takes A7
and then six Checkmate what type of
Checkmate is that do we
know very good right very very good now
the more the bigger pattern for that
would be for example this position why
to Checkmate in two
moves
yes queen queen
G8 Rook take
G8 and
right
to excellent job this is the classical
pattern of Checkmate in of SM mate but
we can actually take this pattern many
more
moves for example let's say that this
was the
position we know how to Checkmate here
right we're going to give
check if it
takes check now we will go to check me
on
the back
rank yeah yeah I'm not saying this I'm
just showing the pattern King Mo goes
here now we have a double check he has
to
go and once again Checkmate in for moves
all righty why to play Checkmate in two
moves
yes
to
F7 okay thank you all right Queen takes
F7 okay you know we do it two three four
times it will be automatic Queen takes
F7 wait wait black will play Black will
play to move to k h okay we don't need
to move the pieces right we'll do it now
in our head K Queen take F7 the King has
to go to the corner King h8 and then um
Knight
to
G6 exactly check one
move check M okay those are tiny bit too
easy for all of you okay we'll get tiny
bit more challenging ones wa to
play you know
but the king can take it
no the
Knight night here
here
here here F6 right okay Knight captures
F6 right you see if you will tell do one
speak like this how would I know Knight
captures F6 what would black
play Black has one move
right yes
Isabelle only move because it's double
check right can we capture in double
check can we Block in double check
so King goes through
there and
now no
move all
right that's a Checkmate pattern it's
very kind of cool how a knight like
controls everything and the r controls
the other square and the king is
just just just checkm in the corner just
by Night
end and The
Rook
like okay check my two
now like I put all the pieces in
something seems like this is a hard one
hard one it's like a magician one
Isabelle do you have one what G Rook G7
okay black has two possibilities right
so you need to tell me what happens in
both possibilities let's start if he
moves this King to E8
any check on the file is going to be
Checkmate perfect and the other Possible
movies
capture then what is a
bell
yes
capture two reasons why no one the
Knight can capture it right no no the
pawn on6 then the king will capture The
Rook who is protecting The
Rook
yesen move
to Queen
D4
check we have to think about you see
this this
is why those why and what those puzzles
are teaching you Rook G7 is perfect but
there are two possibilities for black
right King E8 you're perfect but what if
King if what what if there was a Pawn on
C5 then there was no Queen D4 then maybe
it's a wrong
move right second thing when we suggest
Queen take D6 checkm this is something
for all of you in a game to think when
you tell yourself Checkmate and I've
seen some kids tournament one kid tell
the other check mate and okay and there
is no Checkmate on the board I've seen
many or heard about many many many games
that kids resign his opponent play a
move that is check here like something
like this you play this no
many and one kid thinks it's a Checkmate
no not not God forbid like trying to
fool his opponent really thinks it's a
Checkmate look at his opponent say check
me the other one looks at the board say
oh okay shaking hand and he it's not
well not once not twice many many many
times it happened what what what what
should we study from that when you think
it's a Checkmate when you really think
it's a Checkmate doesn't matter if you
preferably you're checkmating your
opponent but doesn't matter seriously
ask yourself quietly but in your head
okay is there any way to capture the
queen that's threatening check no is
there any way to block
no is there any way to move the king
including captures just move the king
out of the check
yes right actually I for I didn't even I
was so I was so much about that I okay
wait I can tell you how I'll put this
one here for
you you see all right no way to capture
the
que but you know my point was I wasn't
even actually seriously I I didn't see
that side of the boat but it doesn't
matter once you have one of those right
you don't need to ask anymore it's not a
Checkmate once once you get one of those
okay I can move the king but thank you
you're right once you get one of those
right that's it and it's really
important I'm telling you super
seriously you play game and if your
opponent say Checkmate you don't have to
believe it I mean maybe it's right okay
you look you check I cannot move I
cannot capture I cannot block okay it's
Checkmate good game or you checkmating
you know that there is Checkmate in two
moves here and you know that your
opponent can play whatever crazy move
just to give a check and then it would
not be Checkmate in two moves so you
have to find something super forcing
check but in a game can you think that
way no does someone hold a sign in a
game and telling you Checkmate in two
moves
okay you're not going to believe it you
know if if you come I I can tell you
from myself I looked at some
positions and wow they're
complicated and I look like let's say
for whatever time and they're not so
easy for me
whatever then listen to that add I look
at the position and it's not clear to me
then I click on the computer to see what
the computer's thinking the computer
shows why it is winning I don't even see
I I don't look at the line that why that
he's saying I don't just the fact that
computer telling me why is winning I go
back and I find it in half a second half
a minute seriously I know so I what what
does it tell me it tells me that the
line that I was looking before and I
said maybe it's not clear I need to look
one or two steps further and see a win
most likely just someone hinting and
that's you know Kasparov once said that
if you take any grandm I think it's tiny
bit too much but you take any grandmas
or more or decent Grand Masters and you
allow them to use a computer three times
in a game they will play like world
champions this is why puzzles I always
compare it to this way when I put a
position and tell you what is the topic
of the puzzle it's like there is some
Big Field here and I'm telling you there
is a treasure and you should start
digging on the right corner not only I
tell you there's a treasure but I tell
you also where to dig Checkmate in two
moves if I just put a
puzzle it means I tell you this is the
field there is a treasure well maybe
it's a fork maybe it's a pin start
digging here in a game I tell you hey
this is a field maybe you have a
treasure maybe not start digging have
fun that's the big difference that's why
puzzles are much easier it's like like
in every sport like okay if you are
shooting to the basket or shooting to
the basket when there are 30,000 people
screaming against you 2 seconds to the
end of the game when you have to make a
shot right so that's why we have to make
so many puzzles so so many
that it becomes kind of a routine a
pattern easy for us in a game nobody is
holding a sign never okay now Checkmate
in two moves and what you said before is
going to be also right
here oh
yeah
Isabelle do you know you think you know
you know you know okay what do you
know King G7 only
move right and right again ADI strategy
is making it easier to that puzzle
because if white doesn't play a check
and white actually has one check in the
position it doesn't matter where black
is going to check black can play Queen
H1 check it's just not going to be
Checkmate in two moves doesn't matter
now actually I'm going to ask you a
question okay so this is the answer that
Isabelle suggested which is correct now
I have a question let's say white play
this move black here I'll flip the ball
to make it
easy black to Checkmate
in three
moves black to check are you certain you
know black to Checkmate in three
moves certain or not certain um almost
certain
okay 2 King
H1 um Bishop G3 King
G1 and then Queen
H2 I'm certain that you have it very
good and very good and you know this
pattern and you answer very good
check the king cannot Escape right here
we took away this Escape Square for the
king
and now this crucial check continuing to
take away the Escape Square for the king
because after this
move this is our Checkmate and that's
why we need the bishop here excellent
job
dude white to
play
why to play Checkmate in two moves it's
a bit
tricky
yeah you're welcome I yeah yeah yeah
yeah no no you're totally right and
White Queen is under
attack see do you think you know wait
okay you will answer first I just want
to give two one two more minutes for
everyone
two moves two moves two
moves
white it's not you are you thinking
about Rook
f8 are you thinking about Rook
f8 did you said why check me
tonight no there's no but which move
you're thinking for
white f8 yeah but it's not Che me that's
what I said that I know what you're
thinking but you're overlooking King
E7
no see it do you see Checkmate in two
moves
no yes Rook D7 check King E King
go but there are many reasons why not
let's see King can go to
G8 and if you go here and now you want
to protect it I can BL
I can
move many many many reasons why not
important yes
I okay Rook to f8 but then I'm going to
play King
E7 no Checkmate in two
moves
yes
go f8 Knight goes to but here here
immediately without without thinking
half a move
more I'm going to use ADI strategy check
you're going to move your
king okay you play two moves it's not
Checkmate because it's Checkmate in two
you cannot allow the opponent to check
you yes the queen captures the bishop
Knight capture or did we see that the
Knight can capture Bishop Queen captures
the bishop okay I will capture your
queen
that's what we overlooked right but also
if I don't capture it's no Checkmate
like can capture here it's not a
Checkmate
okay one more
move
if White
Queen will get to E8 is it
Checkmate do we know I I think I know
the answer what is it Knight G5 exactly
H or H take or queen take doesn't matter
and in
both so you know sometimes when it's not
that easy to solve we need to ask
ourself where the pieces will be for it
to be Checkmate seriously like like you
know you put puzzles pieces on a well
it's a chest puzzle but like pieces okay
if the queen is here and The Rook is
here it's Checkmate can I get it look if
the queen gets to E8 it's Checkmate we
have to get there by force if not check
check only Knight to G5 is going to is a
check that allows us to go to E8 pay the
way for the queen to goes to E8 why to
play play and Checkmate in two
moves we know fast yeah okay I will let
you answer but but I want to see more
hands okay let me just see okay two more
minutes we let everyone think and then
we can
speak all right you can tell
me black has two possibilities
right he can take the Rook or he can
play B5
right and it doesn't
matter one
we Bishop C7 excellent job perfect and
doesn't matter which one very good
very very
good and the
same yeah this why before is not working
because it allows the king to capture
but this is just
beautiful very
good